to me this felt like a movie like a
Cameron Crowe or a Jim Brooks movies
those are my favorite kinds of movies
part of why I want to be a producer was
almost like you know broadcast news and
and I loved I just loved that it had
deep emotion and deep comedy to it and
and so you know we set out to get it
made and as well said I can we had had a
hard journey as as every movie does I
guess these days but for me it's always
about the material first I really joke
about the size but whether a piece of
material is you know that lends itself
to a big budget or small budget kind of
comes later it's whether or not like I
see the movie and it's something that I
want to work passionately on for years
of my life so and that's this really
spoke to me Rashidah and I actually
dated for three weeks in 1999 it was an
ill-fated romance my sister Mary
McCormack is a great actress and she was
doing a film with her sheet at the time
and she set us up on a date and she said
that we were gonna be soul mates and we
are and we found out that we were better
as best friends and as writing partners
and we don't have to get divorced so but
you know we had both been through
dysfunctional relationships with exes
that were really hard to interpret and
we didn't want to let go but we didn't
want to move on and it felt like this
sort of relationship purgatory that felt
like a lot of people we knew went
through and we thought it would make a
good premise for a film so we had had
several stops and starts at trying to
write screenplays and then finally we
got a little older and I think cared
less about what people thought and I
don't think people were thinking at all
they were just like oh we're writing the
script they're like great so it's
Hollywood sort of everyone's writing a
script you know so we didn't have a lot
of pressure and we just had a really
great working relationship and we liked
the idea and we didn't think it was
terrible and we sent it to Jennifer who
I've known since the boiler room she
gave me my first acting job ever out of
college I met her at the audition and
she liked it and we thought oh no this
might be okay and then we met Lee and
we're like oh god this might be a real
movie like Jen and Lee want to work at
it and it took several stops and starts
but we got it made last summer and went
to Sundance
I'm sold it to Sony and now it's out it
open yesterday it's totally nuts we all
sort of agreed that we didn't want to do
the postcard version of Los Angeles but
we also wanted to make sure the film
felt like it had scope and and we that
we got to see the city and and so I
think it was about finding a balance and
also about sort of honing in on parts of
the city and not trying to do all of la
means sometimes you see NLA movie and
you know in one minute they're on the
Venice Boardwalk and then you know ten
minutes later they're supposed to be in
Silver Lake and then they're supposed to
be in Eagle Rock and you know the palace
traffic so we were we were really trying
to make it feel like a neighborhood that
Celeste and Jesse would have lived in
and the neighborhood their friends would
have lived in in the bars that we they
would have gone in the bars that Paul
might have taken Celeste to if he was
trying to be cool and do something
outside of Westwood do something a
little bit as he saw it
you know hipper the the house that's
supposed to be Celeste house in the film
until for four days before production I
mean for four months it was going to be
Rashida's actual home because we could
not afford to pay for a house you
couldn't afford to shoot in her own
house I'm a character actor and you know
my favorite actors are Harry Dean
Stanton and David Strathairn and the the
last ten roles that I've gotten have
been really character II things and you
know if I could play roles like skills
and movies forever I would be really
really happy but Andy had known rashida
for a long time and and and Lee was a
big proponent of Andy playing the part
and they have a real sort of intimacy
that rashida and I have and it was just
really really thrilling to watch
Andy do this thing for the first time
that I mean I think Andy's a comic
genius but he's never done something
this subtle and simple and nuanced and
real and watching him do it was really
really thrilling and I was really happy
to get the part of skills so I'm a woman
I like to see real women in movies and
I've been talking a lot about how it's
interesting when you're developing a
studio film you know to make
woman likable you know the script always
has to start with her sort of losing her
job getting dumped by a guy tripping
down tripping in high heels you know
it's like sort of the requisite what you
have to do to then be likeable and be
picked back up and have someone fall in
love with you and it's sort of you know
the rules that we sadly it develops a
lot of stories by and that's what I
loved about this is she felt like such a
real character to me she was so
recognizable I see myself in Celeste I
see my friends and Celeste you know and
I like that we didn't I think she is a
likable character I relate to her so
much but I like that we weren't
concerned about it you know that you
were just presenting somebody who felt
very real to me